es oficial Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
está de vuelta en plan alto por tercera
vez aunque ahora le espera un camino
plagado de retos uno de los principales
la profunda división de Brasil y no solo
en las calles donde la polarización es
patente también en el congreso donde el
partido liberal de bolsonaro tiene la
mayoría de asientos y es que para
aprobar proyectos de ley Lula necesitan
más de la mitad de los votos en la
cámara de los diputados y el senado Y al
menos dos tercios para modificar la
Constitución algo para lo que necesitará
de su capacidad de diálogo
en este 30 de octubre histórico la
mayoría del pueblo brasileño dejó Claro
que desea más y no menos democracia
Lula también deberá hacer frente a una
economía debilitada con una desigualdad
y crisis social arrastrada desde finales
del gobierno de Dilma Rousseff y
agravada por el ultraliberalismo del
gobierno de bolsonaro hay tareas
pendientes establecer una reforma
tributaria bajar el desempleo e impulsar
el crecimiento del país en la actualidad
cerca del 30% de la población del país
vive en condiciones de pobreza la
protección del medio ambiente una de las
promesas más sonadas durante su campaña
vamos a respetar nuestra amazonía
nuestros bosques
tampoco será fácil con la deforestación
de la amazonía en niveles récord lo más
complejo será protegerla sin dinamitar
su relación con el agronegocio
Solo quiero que me respeten como les
respeto yo a ellos el verdadero
empresario agroalimentario sabe que no
puede quemar en cierto lugares y que no
puede talar bosques donde no se puede
quemar
en la Esfera internacional el petista
carga con el peso de volver a situar a
su país en el mapa e intentar salir del
aislamiento al que lo el distanciamiento
de bolsonaro con todos los países
progresistas de la región todo para
intentar acercarse al Brasil que ha
prometido a sus votantes